[Music]
reinvention to me means letting go of
everything you've done in the past and
embracing an entirely new way of doing
things
[Music]
I think in general my whole life has
been a story of some variants of
reinvention growing up I actually feel
long as time thought I would be a
professional chess player so within the
ages of 5 and 14 I traveled around the
US and some parts of the world as well
just playing chess for a long time I
really loved the game and then at age of
14 I decided I try something else
funny now today I would argue that our
whole company is around helping other
companies remit themselves to the early
days of any startup for hard I think for
us especially we knew we were walking
into an industry that again just didn't
exist and so we weren't sure really what
a product even looked like tangibly
second was you know is there a market
for this right I think you know there
was a lot of excitement broadly around
AI and deep learning but we hadn't
really seen companies build commercial
products yet when the third just
fundamental piece was you know was I am
you know the team you had will read the
right people to actually do this for the
first time I think in general my big
realization came actually fairly fairly
early on a company which was I realized
that there are a lot of people out there
that are much better at me and many
things and I think that when you kind of
internalize that it becomes much easier
to hire a team in the early days I was
hiring a team to kind of many ways build
them someone in my image of a task that
I had kind of known up until then of how
to do it today it's quite the opposite
when I hire people I believe that
they're gonna be much better at this
role than me and I let them have
autonomy and ownership over it to
believe in ourselves enough and in spite
of you know evidence and not sit against
you otherwise it was definitely the
hardest part of our journey I think for
me personally we oh yeah and for the
rest of founding team we turned down
other more because we call secure jobs
and more traditional pads to do this but
we really believed in what we're
building
I think those early feelings of of that
type of fear and and and and where your
natural and they're actually in some
ways helpful because it's not even
necessarily about the net hours you work
it's more about the mindset of thinking
you know we have to give this our work
we do everything we have because we
don't know if there's going to be
another one really
[Music]
you